Hi, the topic of this video is scalar triple
product, that is a very important topic for
JEE.
I will probably say this is the most important
topic for JEE, more than cross product more
than dot product because this combines cross
product and dot product.
There are a lot of questions which come in
JEE just based on scalar triple product.
It is a very important concept and I hope
that this video will be able to provide you
a basic understanding of scalar triple product.
The idea behind video is to first introduce
scalar triple product and then do a few problems
on this topic.
There will also be a followup video in which
we will go for more examples of scalar triple
product.
So “what is a scalar triple product”?
Till now we have done dot product which was
a \dot b
We have done cross product which was a \cross
b.
Now this is a scalar triple product.
So as the name suggests — triple means there
are three quantities: vector a, vector b,
vector c — and it is a scalar product.
Like dot product was a scalar product, this
is also a scalar product but there will be
three vector quantities, a b and c.
And the output
Hi, the topic of this video is scalar triple
product, that is a very important topic for
JEE.
I will probably say this is the most important
topic for JEE, more than cross product more
than dot product because this combines cross
product and dot product.
There are a lot of questions which come in
JEE just based on scalar triple product. It
is a very important concept and I hope that
this video will be able to provide you a basic
understanding of scalar triple product.
The idea behind video is to first introduce
scalar triple product and then do a few problems
on this topic.
There will also be a followup video in which
we will go for more examples of scalar triple
product.
So “what is a scalar triple product”?
Till now we have done dot product which was
a \dot b
We have done cross product which was a \cross
b.
Now this is a scalar triple product.
So as the name suggests — triple means there
are three quantities: vector a, vector b,
vector c — and it is a scalar product.
Like dot product was a scalar product, this
is also a scalar product but there will be
three vector quantities, a b and c. And the
output would be a scalar.
Let us first discuss how we can get a scalar
quantity out of three vectors.
Let us say we have vector a, and we have vector
b, and we have vector c.
Now, how can I get a scalar quantity out of
this?
Can I do a \dot b \dot c?
This would mean that (let me put brackets
here) a \dot b is a scalar quantity. And I
cannot dot a scalar with c so. Thus this not
possible.
Can I do a \cross b \cross c.
This would mean that this is a vector quantity
as I am taking a vector crossed with another
vector - and that will give a vector output.
However, we want a scalar output so this is
also not possible. We will also be discussing
what kind of product is this but that is the
part of the next videos.
However, can we do something like this - a
\cross b \dot c. This is vector dotted with
another vector, and thus gives us scalar output.
This is a correct one. This is what we want
to know.
Scalar tripe product is defined as
a \cross b \dot c. So what does this mean?
How can we then get the answer for the the
scalar tripe product. The expansion would
be something like this.
You can imagine that basically you have \i
component and you multiply all of that with
cx. So rather than doing \i \j \k separately
you can just put cx cy cz in the determinant
at the top.
This is an important property which i have
written down. You are doing a \cross b \dot
c.
Now can you see something else also which
might or might not be that obvious? We know
that (a \cross b) \dot c = c \dot (a \cross
b). We know that because this is a dot product.
Let us call this vector d. Then d \dot c = c
\dot d. So all you are saying is (a \cross
b) dot c = c \dot (a \cross b)
Also, there is a property of determinants
that basically means that you can flip two
rows, the answer would become negative of
the actual answer, and thus if you flip again
(the second time), then the answer would remain
the same.
So if I flip (row) a and (row) c, then (row)
a will come to the top and row (c) will come
to the middle.
Then when I flip (row) b and (row) c, it will
become a b c. In other words (a \cross b)
\dot c can also be written as | ax ay az;
bx by bz; cx cy cz|.
I have done this by flipping rows twice — flipping
c row and a row, and then b row and c row.
However, if you think about this, whatever
was in the \dot came at the top.
I can write this also as a \dot ( b \cross
c).
What I am saying is whatever is in the dot
came at the top row or the single vector came
at the top row.
I have written this down as (a \cross b) \dot
c = a \dot (b \cross c). This is a super important
property.
a \dot (b \cross c) = (a \cross b) \dot c.
In other words, you can flip the sign of \dot
and \cross.
The first property that we have discussed
was this.
The second property that I want to discuss
is (a \cross b) \dot c = a \dot (b \cross
c).
Third property is a \dot (b \cross c) = (a
\cross b) \dot c. And sometimes
this is written as [a b c], since the position
of \dot and \cross doesn’t matter.
It doesn’t matter you are taking dot here
or cross here. It will always come out to
be same.
I hope that this is making sense: we first
said in a determinant and when we flipped
the rows twice the value remains the same.
Also because the top row belonged to the alone
vector, we said a \dot (b \cross c) is same
as (a \cross b) \dot c.
We also know that (a \cross b) \dot c =
c \dot (a \cross b) = (c \cross a) \dot b.
Or this can also be [c a b]. Because now we
are taking the associative property of dot.
Similarly, now I can write this as b \dot
(c \cross a). Am flipping the dots here again,
and now i am changing this as (b \cross c)
\dot a i.e. changing dot and cross. And this
is [b c a].
This is a very very important property.
What i am trying to say here is (a \cross
b) \dot c. This seems to be a cycling property.
Cyclic property says that a should go to b,
and then b should go to c, and then c should
go to a.
So what is happening is [a b c]. You can always
think it terms of cyclic [a b c]
The cycle is always [a b c] and that means
as long as you have [a b c] written in the
correct cycle, then the value remains the
same.
In other words, [a b c] = [c a b] = [b c a].
I just want to highlight one other thing after,
[a b c] = - [a c b].
So if you flip two things, the cycle breaks.
It is not [a b c], it is [a c b] and so you
have broken the cycle. Or you have reversed
the cycle.
So rather than [a b c], you are now going
[a c b].
Thats why you have a negative sign and you
can check that so if you just flip two rows
- just b and c - only once you do row exchange,
then there is negative sign in front of the
determinant.
Thats why there is a negative sign here.
Again you can make the cycle that [a b c]
= - [b a c]. The cycle is again [a c b], not
[a b c].
This [a b c] = - [c b a]
This is a very very important property. I
hope that you are able to now understand what
we are doing.
We discussed a lot of things very quickly.
This is a scalar product: (a \cross b) \dot
c — because (a \cross b) is a vector and
then you are dotting it with (vector) c.
The second thing we discussed was that you
can flip the position of \dot and \cross.
We showed through the determinant property
that when you flip rows twice, you can conclude
that (a \cross b) \dot c = a \dot (b \cross
c).
The third property is that there is a cyclic
property to the whole system.
We saw this by exchanging the \dot and \cross.
And by using the property of dot product i.e.
(a \cross b) \dot c = c \dot (a \cross b).
You should take some time to digest these
things because these will be used in and out.
They are very very important for the chapter
of vectors.
So please please take your time to understand
these things. Slowly go through this by writing
these equations and then you should be able
to understand this.
I don’t think this a very difficult concept
to grasp but for once you have to really understand
it.
So two things: you can exchange the sign of
\dot and \cross, and there is a cyclic property.
For evaluating (a \cross b) \dot c, you can
just use the determinant.
The next thing I want to discuss — like
all other products — is the physical significance.
What is the physical significance of (a \cross
b) \dot c.
What basically we have to realize is that
this condition a \dot ( b \cross c) =0, then
a b c are coplanar.
This is the first part of the significance.
I want to stress on this quite a lot because
you will often use this in questions.
What does this mean?
Let us say you have two vectors, b and c.
Two vectors are always coplanar. If you have
two vectors, you can always pass a plane through
them.
b and c are two vectors and you have passed
a plane through them.
(b \cross c) is a vector which is perpendicular
to both b and c. This is something we have
discussed in the topic of cross product and
if you can’t recall it, please go and check
back the notes on cross product.
Whenever we have (b \cross c), let us say
n, it is perpendicular to both b and c.
What we are saying is that this n vector is
perpendicular to the plane of b and c.
Because b \cross c is n, a \dot n = 0. What
does a \dot n = 0 mean? This mean a and n
are perpendicular.
If a and n are perpendicular, a has to lie
in the plane of b and c. or a, b, c are coplanar.
What does coplanar mean? It means that if
there are three vectors, you can pass a plane
through them.
With two vectors, you can always pass a plane
Let us say three vectors are like this (demonstration),
you cannot pass a plane through them.
Only with two vectors, you can always pass
a plane.
If there are three vectors, you cannot always
pass a plane through them. When can you pass
a plane through them? Whenever a \dot (b \cross
c) = 0 or the scalar triple product = 0.
How are we explaining this?
b \cross c is a vector perpendicular to both
b and c. Or is perpendicular to the plane
of b and c. When a \dot n = 0, that implies
a and (b \cross c) are perpendicular. Since
dot product is zero whenever two vectors are
perpendicular. So this forces a to lie in
the plane of b and c.
This is very important and you just have to
remember that whenever three vectors are coplanar,
the scalar triple product is 0.
Coplanarity also means
that you can represent the third vectors as
linear combination of the first two vectors.
This is also a way to understand coplanarity.
When can you represent a vector as a linear
combination of a and b?
Let us say there are a and b, and a plane
passes through them. Then basically you are
saying that you are stretching one vector
or compressing a vector as l and m can take
any real values.
Let us say you made one vector half and other
vector double, and then now you are adding
them. So basically completing some kind of
addition, and addition forces you to not leave
that plane.
That is why these three things are coplanar.
You can also imagine that if I put c=la+mb
here: if I take cross of b with b, it will
become zero. Then, we will be left with (a
\cross b) \dot a. Then you can flip \dot and
\cross, and it will become (a \cross a) \dot
b. Cross of a with a will also be zero.
You can check. You can just put this expression
back and check that this always comes out
to be zero.
So coplanarity means that one vector can also
be written as the linear combination of other
two vectors, and scalar triple product [a
b c] is zero.
I hope that is giving some insight into the
significance of scalar tripe product.
Dot product was the projection of a vector
on the other vector.
Cross product was the vector perpendicular
to both the vectors.
Scalar triple product = 0 means a condition
for coplanarity.
Second thing that I want you to learn as a
formula, if there is
a parallelopiped — parallelopiped is like
a 3-D parallelogram. Volume of parallelopiped
is [a b c] where three sides are a vector,
b vector and c vector.
There are a lot of proofs for this but I don’t
think you need to understand the proofs.
a vector is this entire side, c vector is
this entire side, and b vector is this entire
side. Then the volume of parallelopiped is
[a b c].
If there is a tetrahedron, with sides a, b
and c, then volume would be [a b c]/6.
If this is a little bit unclear to you, don’t
worry too much about this. Just go back and
look at some images of tetrahedron and parallelopiped.
Just remember that whenever the side are a,b
and c, then the volume of parallelopiped is
[a b c] and the volume of tetrahederon is
[a b c]/6.
Let us recap whatever we have discussed. This
ends the property discussion of scalar triple
product.
We have discussed that (a \cross b) \dot c
can be written as a determinant.
We also learned that you can flip \dot and
\cross. I showed this by flipping the rows
twice and hence (a \cross b) \dot c = (a \cross
b) \dot c.
Then we learned about the cyclic property
of [a b c]. And that there will be a minus
sign whenever the cycle is broken or reversed.
Then we discussed two things about physical
significance.
Condition for coplanarity: one vector is a
linear combination of other two vectors and
that is also expressed in terms of (a \cross
b) \dot c = 0. Since b \cross c is a vector
perpendicular to the plane of b and c, and
if a \dot n=0, a has to lie in the place of
b and c.
And finally, if a,b and c are sides of parallelepiped
and tetrahedron, then the volume is [a b c]
and [a b c]/6.
These are the properties we have discussed.
Please remember them and learn them. They
should be on your fingertips whenever you
see them.
Let us try to do some very quick problems.
First problem is: If a, b, c are coplanar,
what is
the value of [2a - b, 2b - c, 2c -a]?
We have been told that there are three vectors
a,b,c that are coplanar. Then we have been
asked to find the scalar triple product of
vectors of the linear combination of a,b and
c.
One way to solve this problem is to take a
cross and then take dot, and trying to find
something in terms of [a b c].
My point here is to really make you understand
what this means. Think about three vectors
that are coplanar: you have two vectors like
this and third vector like this — they are
in a plane.
What you are doing is that you are just taking
a linear combination of these three vectors.
Can you ever go out of the plane? Can you
ever create a vector which is out of the plane?
For instance, if c = la + mb, since a, b,
c are coplanar.
Then 2a-b is a linear combination of a and
b.
2b-c, because c = la + mb, is also a linear
combination of a and b.
2c-a is also a linear combination of a and
c.
So even all these vectors are just linear
combination of a and b. That means that they
are in the same plane. So you don’t even
need to do anything. You don’t have to calculate.
You can just directly write that this is equal
to zero.
Because a, b, c are coplanar, any linear combination
of these vectors will also lie in the same
plane. So these three vectors are in the same
plane. So you just have to understand that
since these vectors a coplanar, their linear
combinations has to be coplanar, so this has
to be zero since this is condition of scalar
triple product.
I can bet that a lot of students will try
to solve this problem. They will start with
[a b c]=0 and then they will expand this by
taking a cross here and dot here, and opening
up the brackets and trying to solve it somehow.
All you have to do is to understand that coplanarity
means that that linear combination of the
vectors will lie in the same plane.
I hope that this gives you some insight about
scalar triple product.
The second problem that I want to do is: What
is the value of \lambda such that \lambda
\i + \j + \k, \i + 2 \lambda \j + \k and \i
+ \j + \k are coplanar.
So what is
the value of \lambda such that these three
vectors are coplanar.
The question is begging you to remember the
condition of coplanarity that a \dot (b \cross
c) = 0. Thats it.
How can we write a \dot (b \cross c) is as
we have discussed a determinant. Let us call
this a vector, b vector and c vector.
Then a \dot (b \cross c) = |\lambda 1 1; 1
2\lamba 1; 1 1 1 | = 0.
I hope with time you will become quick in
opening up determinants.
If you open up the determinant, you will find
that this is 2 \lambda ^ 2 - 3 \lambda + 1
= 0. You can check that this what it comes
out.
That would give you the answer \lambda = 1,
1/2. In an objective test, this could be a
multiple-choice problem.
Can we check what the answer \lambda = 1 mean?
If \lambda = 1, then this becomes \i + \j
+ \k and then this becomes \i + \j + \k. So
they are same vectors. So if they are the
same vectors, that means their cross will
always be zero.
So if they are the same vectors, this basically
become two vectors, which will obviously be
coplanar. Rather than three vectors, you have
basically two vectors which are always coplanar.
If \lambda=1/2, then this become \i + \j +
\k, and then these two become same. So again
they become two vectors and they are always
coplanar.
I hope that with this you are physically able
to understand the meaning of scale triple
product.
In this video, we covered very important topic
of scalar triple product. We discussed its
properties. We discussed 4 properties. And
then we did two examples to understand the
meaning of scalar triple product and how to
apply it.
In the next video, we will discuss vector
triple product. If you enjoyed this video,
please check out the next video. Thank you!